in realtà ragazzi dovrei studiare perché
ciò i quiz da fare per la patente indica
la fine della prescrizione del divieto è
uscito un gioco per guardavo [ __ ]
pecore
così si parla bene a tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo video sono frange
dati siamo su robinson che non è un
telefilm in teoria poi non lo so
dovrebbe essere una figata visto il
caricamento che dura dodici anni e mezzo
quindi perfetto che aveva madonna se
facciamo gioca ancora non sapere neanche
di che parla proviamo solo vedere by
bastati i caricamenti che poi in realtà
ragazzi gioco e questo il caricamento e
bellissimo da vedere bisogna fissare la
barra mentre carica bellissimo il
viaggio di un'astronave il termine entro
genia e grazie a dio non guidavo io
anche la gancia patente un ragazzo
raggiunge la superficie
ma non è solo xtc addio scansioni i maya
sono un ragazzo veicolo si tratta del
nido di un tirannosauro questo questa
lite rischiano sauro che culo di merda
cadere sono qua eh già ciao frate quel
coso morte per carlton pietro non lo so
destra ricatto indietro provincia milano
fratello non posso meno laica ma non è
vero
bastano voglia non ha detto io giuro a
casa ti chiamano laica qualcuno l'ha
detta grossa di mangia tre mesi dopo la
tua testa intersecata con un oggetto è
un modo per dirmi che sono testa di
cazzo ok ho un figlio travis per
interagire con gli oggetti ok punto
possiamo su questo pianeta
385 giorni marcelo graz
clicca per interagire con gli oggetti si
[Musica]
vabbè mi chiamino tanto più guarderesti
niassa il ragazzo era una navicella
bellissima vero devono essere scesi al
pacha calidonna dov'è andata laica
perché non provi a chiamarla si nasconde
per la vergogna perché cosa fatta cagato
in casa posso farti una domanda ma io
possa andare in giro dove vogliono
la ragazza femmine è bellissimo cioè non
sto leggendo il colpo è la madonna big
ad inler chiosa rilasciare dopo far
cadere gli spara lanciare scusa non mi
avvicinerei troppo a quel recinto
frateschi nei due alle braccia
ok comando io se spunta un ragno d'amato
due set a marzo la palla prima che la
lascia la faccia sarà come guarda la
palla
quanto vorrei che una ragazza
riguardasse come like a guardare la
palla con tumore che una ragazza
guardasse la mia palla quanto like a
guardar bene veloce 32 anni ora da casa
me la immaginavo molto più reattiva
prova ben conosce la strada è il tomtom
non serve più una sega nel 2000 euro
ottocento laica vuoi giocare ad albino e
c 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 ma fai cagare
ho visto sei al punto 6 appunto 4 3 2 1
vengo a cercarti querelle se non vale
però sti stronzi
il pane al pane un gioco quando lo fa
serio vuoto equa suo che rail ma
focherello opposta se devi dare i
consigli dagli bene non sei capace e
questo qualcosa luongo ma sai come si
danno i consigli intelligente portiere e
il poker è anche lì comunque se un po
rincoglionito
ecco quella è un'unità hicks contiene
dati preziosi prevista lega sono
immediata robin palco da questa parte ha
finalmente era ora di fare due passi
nella foresta così che belli questi
fiori che sono anche in giardino però in
guardia gli sono molto più belli quindi
fate secoli andare in giardino porto
suicidarmi bellissimo panni può
sfruttare un t rex da un momento
all'altro delicato in mano tipo sean
byrne che schifo di werner e gatti sta
rompendo le palle sei finito c'è un modo
per mutarlo vi prego mi dà fastidio che
mira a far paura sia
si mette sempre nei guai
lui non mi dispero
ma io non sono l'unico a trovare
fastidiosa alla tua cucciola pensa che
questa cosa più che una salita male
stronzo una lama quanto è grosso frate
io c'ho dinosauro grosso però c'è anche
dinosauro il grosso più grosso va bene
forse il camminare nella meta non posso
camminare amherd abili portate dirlo
però d'ora in poi qualche rai è stato
bellissimo per un altro questo
bellissimo quel momento in cui sono
morto no però quante persone possono
dire di essere state schiacciate da un
come che si chiama cosa fare ma io non
saranno di carni scusa
ok avanti car ti ricordi come si fa a
vero robbie ok ma sono entrambe le mani
ma posso legarmi chi è quel che cos'è ok
ma cos'è sta roba
vai via pola serie la gaming è la mia
postazione da gaming quacci video berti
ragazzi per tutte questo nuovo blog
nella foresta del i dinosauri ma cos'è
no non lo farò mai darà un frate che
andava mita giuro ma lei esattore manila
se anche tu adesso no frate davvero bach
con allora vale lento a va bene allora
ecco che ci sono gli pterosauri dietro
al marzo mi spiegate perchè mi dovete
far scalare le cose che mi sta in culo a
per scalare le cose perché dovete fargli
scalare le cose che palle ma cosa che un
tragico e fallo tu se non fosse che
imitano un po in mano prove
cioè io vi giuro stare qua sembra
veramente di stare
ok ok
certo c'è che sta facendo questo perso
dal tuo pc ore e mezza e vita un
fastidio quanto tempo per salire con
salve e stato bellissimo
ok poi incrocia le braccia
va bene va bene perfetto vi dovete
togliere
date fastidio maria tosto incornato
intonato e poi ok grazie ma da poeti
uffici io però non ho fatto niente non
sono anche caduto madama marzo vale
ragazzuoli sarebbe bello del fantastico
e stato allora che mi spunta dinosauro
dal momento all'altro che mi mangia se
la faccia prove ragazzo verrebbe subito
vi sia piaciuto è stato alquanto figo
provare un gioco per quale così fatto
bene che stava veramente fatto da dio e
yepes flamini 6 per cento ragazzi
consente più visto sul momento è un mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e con
il diavolo possiamo video io ai miei
capelli stupendi
da ragazzino